[Musique]
les chevaliers ouvre installer une
oreille séquencé pour une personne
attend peu plus ma fille ma fille si ça
vous dérange pas vous avez une
oreillette dock pour eux
voilà on a chacun une oreillette on est
à bfm deux brèches mais il édicte de
saloperies lège l'oreille défensif et
vous demande d'être ucao aux délices et
on se croirait dans une boîte à partouze
on est toujours chez larry flynt ouais
alors je vous posais des questions vous
allez devoir répondre ce que vous dites
baffie dans l'oreillette
alors éric c'est quoi la vente âge de
travailler à deux pendant les tournées
on économise ne put on fait des
économies tu vas en tournée on économise
le but concédé ce truc vous n'allez pas
le but partout quand même ce procès
c'est quoi le pire truc que vous ayez
fait dans la simca 1000 on a mis deux
fiat 500 en fait
eric c'est quoi votre rituel avant de
monter sur scène on recompte la recette
[Rires]
là il me permet plus que tu vas chez
tout le monde je répondrais ceci c'est à
dire que nous c'est beaucoup plus loi
comptait que toi voici comment vous avez
choisi le nom des chevaliers du fiel
au départ on voulait appeler ça les
chevaliers du fuel est totale nous a
fait un procès à eux au départ en fait
on avait choisi des chevaliers du fuel
et c'est total qui nous a fait un procès
j'aurais cru j'aurais cru ma fille
aurait dit il j'ai ils ont voulu simple
et chevaliers du fion eric est la
personne qui vous fait le plus rire en
suisse quand il se retire pas sa passe
oui ça passe ça passe d'offir sa part si
ça passe vous êtes les plus grosses
stars de l'humour dans le sud à la note
pratiquement en france alors est ce que
j'ai un message à faire passer aux gens
du nord nous intéresse
[Applaudissements]